what do you think about the spotify
thing
what about it ask me a question he's now
as opposed to being
just a comedian with a podcast he now
is just a comedian with the podcast who
stepped like in the middle of
the center of cancer culture which is
like it's
i know spotify is in sweden but they
represent
silicon valley they represent the very
kind of
structures they contain and represent
the kind of structures that threaten to
destroy the elons of the world
and he just like stepped like with his
alex jones and his
uh joey diaz just strolled right into
the middle of it
i think it's awesome i love it but do
you think he'll he's strong enough to
well i don't know i mean i don't even
know the right way to ask this but
is he strong enough to persevere it's a
bit interesting it's like when alliance
decides wow that honey badger looks
tasty i'm gonna swallow it whole
see what happens because i talked to him
offline
he really seems to be willing to give
away the 100 million
which gives him so much power oh
i don't it's a powerful thing to be able
to say i don't
yeah to the the honey badger he just
strolls in but he's willing to walk away
from anything in this well he's gonna
walk out the other side of the the lion
i don't think he's gonna go out the way
he came in
yeah well you know what it is it's it's
tommy lee jones entering the bug
this is like a giant alien he just walks
into it he just he gets swallowed by the
bug and he blasts out from the inside
yeah
i have it as tommy lee jones yeah but
anyway
yeah is that my feeling is that spotify
doesn't understand what they're messing
with
i could be wrong but i'm i'm not no
you're right i'm right
because joe doesn't need anything man i
mean this is the weird thing about it
it's like i'm sure that he loves all his
toys whatever blah blah blah he's a rich
guy
yes he's got fu money he had fu money a
long time ago
and you're not you know the
the other thing about it's a bit weird
being friends with a dude like that
it just is because like you call him up
or he'll call you up and he's like i
said
what's going on in your life i don't
know kind of depressed
trying to get some math done what are
you up oh dude i can cheer you up i just
came off of a you know 29 000 person
stadium
it's like oh cool how'd you do that oh i
don't know i just announced it on
instagram a few days ago and it filled
up
just like oh damn
you